عقيده روسيه لا تتبدلوا بتغيير حكام
الكامله روسيا يمكنها فقط الاعتماد على
جيشها وعلى عامل اخر حليفا قديم وموثوق
الشتاء من غزوه التتار وحمله نابليون الى
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اراضي روسيا
البارده لمى دافعت عنها اربع وحروبا كبرى
لعب فيها الجنرال الابيض دورا حاسما على
الجليد انكسرت احلامه الزحف المغول باتجاه
اوروبا وفي الشتاء وبسبب البرد ان هزم
السويديون في حرب الشمال الكبرى وخسروا
بذلك سيادتهم على بحر بلطيق وما بين الوحي
والجليد فبددت جيوش حمله
النازيه التي شنها الراي الثالث ضد
الصوفيه فقدت المانيا
حينها بالحرب الخاطئه السكريك الزمن
والصقيع سندس روسيا امام الهن المانيه
اكثر تقدما وحينكه قبل تحقيقها النصر
النهائي لكنه موسكو هذه المره تواجه خصما
يلعب بالورقه نفسها اوكرانيا وتاريخيا لدى
روسيا مشكله ان لعب خصمها بنفس الطريقه
الحمله الصوفيه على فنلندا شتاء عام
1939 روسيا تكبدت 10 اضعاف خسائر حسون
البشريه قبل سيطره عليها والشتاء نفسه
وقتها وقفه ضد ستالين الذي جلس جنونه من
اجل التدفئه واكل السجق اللي يخسروا معركه
عرفت بنفسه اسم الوجبه اذا هو نعمه ونقمه
الشتاء يفرض استراتيجيته على الجيوش
السباق انطلق منذ اسابيع روسيا تريد تسميد
الحرب والحفاظ على ما كسبته من اراد حتى
الربيع اما كياب فتلعب كل اوراقها من اجل
تعويض ما خسرته قبل فوات الاوان
ما بدايه الشتاء القارس في روسيا الذي
يحمل معه درجات حراره منخفضه تصل احيانا
الى دون 30 درجه مئويه يبدا فصل جديد من
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وجوله جديده من الصعوبات امام القوات
الروسيه خاصه مع وجود نفس في تجهيز جنود
الروس الذين تمت زياده اعدادهم مؤخرا
صعوبات عند قد تواجهها القوات الروسيه في
ارض المعركه بحسب تقارير بدءا من صعوبات
في تشغيل المعدات العسكريه ومرورا بالحاجه
للمزيد من الوقود لتشغيل المعدات
وامكانيات اخفاء الالغام تحت الجليد
وانتهاء بامكانيه تحرك الامدادات في الليل
فقط لان الغطاء الميداني سيصبح اقل امور
كلها ستدفع القوات الروسيه لتغيير
الاستراتيجيه
دفاع وليس الهجوم